paris
il
quand même
la couche la vie
on
moi
les départs avec les
nous allons
bien la finir deux contre un
françois davy
bonsoir c'est la vraie chasse et que je
suis sûr qu'on peut laisser des lèvres
est beau je vous embrasse
pour mon fils et mon mari qui vous adore
moi je suis toujours oui c'est pas
gentil il s'est calé olivier fred duval
dahl wolfe françois je suis sûr vous
n'êtes pas du tout contente des chansons
que j'ai choisi a quand même une affaire
froid qui sait que la première en tous
les cas vous l'avez pas du tout mais les
autres ça va justement j'en suis un
petit peu fatigué oui comment ça va vous
avez l'air chaud devant moi aussi je
suis très heureux de vous voir
sérieusement
alors oui oui vous êtes très critique
sur vos premiers disent lire écouter
jamais il parlait sur les derniers aussi
en tous les cas il ya une chanson de
vous qui sort actuellement et qu'on
écoutera encore dans dix ans dans les
émissions de télévision
magnéto serge